[Music]
all right well let's turn to tomorrow
because that is when Taylor Swift's new
album reputation will drop and Kelsey I
gotta say Taylor has been promoting this
album all over the place huh all over
her social media but a new report claims
that Tay Tay's reputation for watching
over every little detail has gone too
far
are you ready for
I wouldn't want to do this if I didn't
have a hundred percent control over what
I wear what my message is what my lyrics
are the new headlines
Taylor is overbearingly protective of
her image made a demand for full
editorial control and she doesn't feel
like she needs to do interviews to sell
albums anymore so hashtag on full blown
diva here's what we know Taylor has no
sit-down interview scheduled who won big
appearance performing live on this
week's SNL the 27 year old has also kind
of become her own social media machine
dropping behind the scenes of her music
videos and she did four secret sessions
allowing only 500 fans to get a listen
of her new album Hayes also been super
secretive with the other thing we all
love her relationship with her new
boyfriend Joe Alwyn
so what does Taylor think about all the
smack talk bashing her image wounded by
it and you don't understand why someone
would would make something up about you
like that and you think it's personal
and really it's honestly a money thing
blogs need to write about me to get hits
it's a money thing you just laugh at it
and listen Taylor is laughing all the
way to the bank reputation is already
projected to be the biggest selling
album of her career now none of the
singles have really hit me at home yet
so I'm excited to hear the whole record
sometimes artists have to do that album
for themselves creatively you know and
Taylor does what Taylor wants believe
that